Now that we've run the model, let us go
view the results in the browse tool and
I'll walk you through the main
points of this output.
What we're able to see
first is in record one,
and what I look at here is
the loss function distribution.
And like we set as default before
is going to be the multinomial
option which means we have a categorical
variable that we're trying to predict.
And these categories is more than two,
it's three or greater, so
these were non-binary type of
classification problem that we have.
The other thing that I see is
the number of trees that were used.
So before with the force
model we used 500 trees.
With the decision tree,
we used one tree.
Over here, he used 4,000 and
that was actually a maximum threshold.
So really this model probably
took a very long time to run
because it created 4,000 trees,
but most likely,
there's a very good chance it's going to
be more accurate than the other models.
What I look at then is next in record
two, this variable importance plot
that we see in both the forest model and
the decision tree model.
And we're able to see which
variables are most important
to each of these different models.
And so it looks like,
just like we saw before,
the distance that someone
lives away from their work
is the most important variable to
the model then after that, age.
While gender and marital status don't
even contribute at all to this model.
Record three are the number
of iteration assessment plot.
What this shows is
the amount of variance or
rather deviance that is
captured with more iterations.
And what this shows is
that the more trees added
the smarter the prediction became.
As well the estimation sample and
the in-model sample that are both
bill in this model are very close.
Meaning this model performs
well on an independent sample.
We're going to continue to test
how well this model performs.
With the now scoring the validation
sample, with the model comparison tool.